i really want to start with a sincere uh
those that opening of spider-man this
new one is uh fantastic
i can't wait to see the rest yeah i
cannot wait um so i am curious um how
long have you guys been planning the
multiverse and did that timetable get
moved up or changed as a result of the
acquisition of the fox characters
uh you know i think we first mentioned
it i think the ancient one mentions it
in uh in doctor strange one uh when
she's taking stephen strange through
that sort of mind-warping journey uh and
it was always one of the most powerful
storytelling tools in the comics one you
have to wield carefully uh because it
can get overwhelming um but one that now
with you know obviously the the 60 to 80
year history of the comics
now we have a 20-plus history of the
movies uh and there are enough
characters that we can start playing
with it that way so it was and we
mentioned it obviously as part of
mysterio's ruse
in far from home
um but no i don't think it was
i think the the toys that were added to
the toy box uh increased with that fox
acquisition but it didn't change the
time table on when we were introducing
uh the idea of the multiverse
obviously every mcu builds on each other
but it does feel like this spider-man
movie and the upcoming doctor strange
movie could really reshape the mcu in a
completely new direction um
is it safe to say that this is like a
dramatic is there anything what
like with those two films is it safe to
say this is like a dramatic change
coming to the mcu
uh i i think yes i mean whenever we tap
into
an entire
subgenre of the comics or an entire
realm of storytelling possibility from
the comics that just increases what
we're able to do in the in the movies
i would add for people following along
with the mcu loki in the final episode
of loki to that in terms of how and why
sort of what what you are about to see
is is possible and why it's happening
uh is the multiverse the first steps
towards the eventual secret wars movie
uh every movie is a step towards the
next one steve
sure i understand i'm just i'm anyway
i'm looking forward to an eventual
secret wars thing um you've made so many
challenging movies um running uh marvel
how would you rank uh this spider-man
movie if you were gonna give it like a
one through ten in terms of the
difficulty of pulling this one off
um i mean they're all a ten any movie is
the ten eternal shanxi black widow from
this year were all tens in terms of how
hard the universe doesn't want movies to
happen for some reason um and you uh and
you have to fight against everything to
bring them to fruition
you know this one it's often the people
you're working with and and amy pascal
and john watts and the whole team
between the marvel studios team and the
sony team worked so well together and
are so passionate about spidey and this
character that that makes everything
much easier but i think you know going
back to
to civil war
and sort of having an idea for a movie
that is based entirely on
what actors and what characters we can
get to work together and and shoot on a
single day um
when that worked it gave us the the the
ambition
for movies like infinity war endgame and
i would include no way home into that
level of ambition for sure
the ending of the recent venom sequel
puts venom in the mcu which a lot of
fans are overjoyed about how long had
you been planning on doing something
like that or how long had that been in
the works
well i mean you look at the that at the
obvious comic connotations between venom
and spider-man and it is
it's inherent uh so so the minute sony
made their venom movie and it worked as
well as it did and tom hardy became as
iconic uh as he has become his venom
then the obvious questions and and how
do we how do we start to to merge them
i'm already out of time i'm just going
to stop and say thank you i sincerely
cannot wait to see the finished film all
right steve good seeing you
you